hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in the second last chapter of his work
black skin white mask franz fanon has a
section
called the negro and hegel and a lot of
that section
is focused on what's often erroneously
called the master slave dialectic
it's actually the dialectic of
self-consciousness
in that early part that the master slave
dialectic is a small
part of after the struggle for
recognition
and the battle to the death and the
subjugation of one of the
consciousnesses but we can put that
aside
for a moment fanon is taking up some
really
important themes and reinterpreting them
as is the case not just for himself but
for
many francophone intellectuals of the
20th century and we should pause here
for a moment
and say a little bit about hegel
and the reception of him and why fanon
is picking up
on hegel so as he tells us the really
key issue here is that of
recognition in hegel's german on air
cannon
and this means to to be acknowledged
as a as a person not just
as a thing not as subhuman but being
treated
as another person and this assumes a
really important role
in the self-consciousness section but
then it runs throughout the rest of the
phenomenology and the master slave
dialectic is actually an unsuccessful
way
of trying to attain recognition both on
the master's part
and what's imposed upon the slave and
then in in the phenomenology there
follow
several other dialectics that come out
of this this
struggle for recognition the master
slave dialectic
the stances of stoicism skepticism
and then this longer section called the
unhappy consciousness now fanon
is not actually going to talk about
those here instead he's going to
move in a different direction but it's
important to
acknowledge that now hegel's
phenomenology was
not that important really in the 19th
century
but in the 20th century it became the
book to read
and so some of the people that fanon
himself
is is drawing upon and reacting against
like for example
jean-paul sartre um also simone de
bevoir
hegel plays an important role in their
works actually gabriel marcel who he
mentions
um was was early on an idealist and then
left that behind
um and so there's a well also jacques
lacan he brings up as well
so there's a lot of like hegel in the
air
and fanon thinks that some of this can
be useful
but not in a like let's follow hegel and
lock
step through this rather adapting it
so this recognition this question well
how are you going to
attain recognition and what does
recognition
actually look like and demand that's
something that hegel
is putting on the map front and center
so we should talk about the dialectic of
self-consciousness and the master slave
dialectic i'm going to give you a real
thumbnail
version of it here so in the
phenomenology
after the consciousness section which
finishes up with one of the toughest
section
of the the book itself uh forcing the
understanding
there's this new start and it has to do
with
with self-consciousness now
self-consciousness
is not just consciousness of something
else but
consciousness of oneself
so it's reflexive it has to do with all
sorts of modalities
that we could call you know valuing
oneself self-esteem
your self-image all these sort of
self-hyphen
things can fit into self-consciousness
now
hegel one of the main contributions he
makes one of the realizations that's
there in the work
is that you don't get self-consciousness
by itself
in a world you know with no other others
and then you know it just runs into
another and then
suddenly you know becomes aware of other
people existing
no we exist as self-consciousness
already in relation to others we that's
part of how we inhabit a world it's
already a
social or relational world and you can
only be
self-consciousness through another
self-consciousness or we
to be more exact through all sorts of
self-consciousnesses
because it's never just as purely dyadic
as hegel makes it out to be
so what we have in hegel's narrative
is these two self-consciousnesses
encounter each other
they want recognition from the other
they're kind of crude they don't really
know how to how to get it in productive
ways
so they engage in a struggle to the
death they attempt to impose
their own importance will whatever we
want to call it
demand upon the other self-consciousness
the other self-consciousness does that
equally to the other
and they both recognize their
commonality so like i better attack that
guy before he attacks me right so
there's there's there's this uh aspect
there that's almost hobbsian
in a way and one of the
self-consciousnesses values its
life more than the other
and gives in or they kill each other
or one mortally wounds the other and
then we start from the start but
where we go from the the dialectic is
one of them knuckles under
and the other one becomes the master the
lord
the hare in german the other becomes the
serf
the slave the servant the kinect
and now we have the dialectic of master
and slave
and here we're not just talking about
individuals we're talking about entire
classes of people we can talk about
dynasties we can talk about all sorts of
things
so the master as an individual and as a
class makes the slave be the
intermediary between
the world of objects that have to be
worked upon and the master
and his or her desire to enjoy
and they do enjoy right the slave makes
things for them it could be like make me
a sandwich or it could be
make me a play that i can watch or make
me some music or
whatever it's going to be you know make
my child be
educated a lot of greek tutors were
serving roman masters
in in the roman empire teaching their
kids
so the master doesn't continue to
develop
the master is kind of left behind except
as
a force to be reckoned with the the
recognition that they get from the slave
is only partial
because they're not treating the slave
as a full person the slave and the
master slave dialectic develops through
having to subordinate themselves through
fear through service
through deferring their own desires and
becomes something more
in the process okay so that's hegel's
you know master slave dialectic typical
sort of take that the marxists really
focused in on and
you know french existentialists and
psychoanalysts also picked up on
including fanon so
what do we have with fun on then well a
little bit earlier in the work
putting aside the references to hegel
where he talks about how this person
um basically you know did a parody of
hegel or stuff like that there's two
main places
that we should look at so the first one
is actually
early on in the discussion of sexuality
and he talks as in chapter three the man
of color and the white woman
he says i wish to be acknowledged not as
black but as white
now and this is a form of recognition
that hegel had not envisaged
who but a white woman can do this for me
by loving me she proves that i am worthy
of white love
i am loved like a white man
i marry white culture white beauty white
whiteness
right and now he's not saying that this
is actually his
own choice or desire he's speaking
in terms of the the person who wants to
appropriate
white culture by developing a
you know lasting relationship in which
they
are acknowledged in which they are
recognized first by their lover
and then hopefully by the rest of
society
by taking on the what belongs to the
master
class or belongs to the elite
class in this case whatever we want to
call it
so there he calls this a recognition
hegel did not
envisage technically that's completely
correct
hegel doesn't talk about anything
remotely like this in the phenomenology
not even in the later parts
so what's going on here we should we
should think about this
why is fanon bringing up hegel at this
point
if he's saying well hegel isn't actually
helpful here
that's something to leave in your mind
for a little bit
then he also brings up leopold senor
talking about cezaire
and here he brings up something a little
bit different that's not coming
straight out of the phenomenology but
out of hegel's
works more generally he says that
now this is this is actually um
uh here we go from jean paul sartre
orfeh noir
the negro as we said creates an
anti-racist racism for himself in no
sense does he wish to rule the world
he seeks the abolition of all ethnic
privileges wherever they come from
he asserts his solidarity with the
oppressed of all colors
at once and here's where it gets
hegelian right
the subjective existential ethnic idea
of negritude
passes as hegel puts it
into the objective positive exact ideal
of the proletariat
for cezaire senor says the white man is
the symbol of
capital as the negro is that of labor
beyond the black-skinned men of his race
it is the battle the world proletariat
that is his song and so
this is you know uh quite important this
is something that plays a turning point
actually as fanon tells us in his own
thinking as he's reading these pages
where
sartre is encapsulating what senor is
saying
about cezaire so it's like you know
participating in this whole conversation
really a conversation of intellectuals
where there's some acknowledgment going
on
but what's the important thing here the
subjective existential idea
of negritude passes into the objective
positive exact idea of proletariat
there's a displacement that's taking
place
and this is typically hegelian hegel
thinks that it's important to move away
from
just the subjective just the
lived experience into something more
essential
something more objective and so
this is a sort of typical marxist
transformation
and senor is actually rejecting that
so what is he doing
uh then in his own appropriation in this
this chapter
uh well sub chapter on uh
well the chapter itself is the negro and
reconciliation
and so he's bringing up hegel and
i i want to say from the start fanon is
using hegel but he's not actually going
to completely endorse hegel here
so it's important to see where he's
actually going
in appropriating hegel he's really
talking about three key
aspects of the struggle for recognition
so one is that recognition is something
that is desired
from the other and we can talk about
desire
for the other and sometimes it can be
desire for the other's desire
but can also be desire for the other's
acknowledgement it could be desire for
the other
treating you as a you know an autonomous
entity having value and so he says
the human being is human only to the
extent to which they try to impose their
existence
on another person in order to be
recognized by them
as long as they haven't been effectively
recognized by the other
that other will remain the theme of
their actions and and this is a great
uh idea to to dwell upon this can be
in terms of recognition
through sexuality think about one who
desires
another and because they can't get that
person to give them the proverbial time
of day
they you know obsess over them or are
they obsessed with people who are like
them
and they find substitutes i'll get you
know i can't get hurt alike me i'll get
hurt like me instead
and it never completely works does it or
it could be entire classes of people i
mean think about the whole insult
culture
and their obsession with you know how
they deserve
uh you know eight to tens even though
there are four
and we go on and on and on you know
that's that's part of this
um desire for recognition and
i should put this too not all desire for
recognition is
rational or reasonable or merited
i could say that i deserve recognition
for being you know the best lecturer
ever in philosophy
i don't deserve that some some desires
for recognition aren't
actually you know rooted in in reality
but that doesn't mean that they don't
exist
and many of them stem from our culture
you know we can think about racial
dynamics the idea
that i ought to be treated differently
because of color of skin or facial
physiognomy
or we could talk about language as he
does in here the difference in dialects
we could also talk about education
we could talk about walking into a bar
and expecting service in a certain way
because i've got
uh you know a credit card or a lot of
money
or something like that all those are
desires for recognition we impose them
upon others and here's where it gets
really interesting
if we coerce it from the other it's not
really recognition
it's kind of a pale substitute for it
isn't it
so desire of the other he goes on a
little bit more
and he says that uh here we go
each consciousness itself is in quest of
absoluteness it wants to be recognized
as a primal value without reference to
life
as a transformation of what hegel calls
subjective certainty
into objective truth when it encounters
resistance from the other
self-consciousness
undergoes the experience of desire and
and
you know this is important he says that
this leads to the dignity of the spirit
self-consciousness
can then risk itself and he says as soon
as i desire i am asking
to be considered i am not merely here
and now sealed into thingness
i am for someone else and for something
else i demand
that notice be taking of my negating
activity
insofar as i pursue something other than
just life
insofar as a beautiful phrase as i do
battle for the creation of a human
world that is of a world of reciprocal
recognitions and so this is a great
lead-in to the next thing we don't just
want
reciprocity in a one-sided way we want
we want reciprocity right we don't want
recognition in a one-sided way we want
a reciprocal recognition we want to be
recognized
by those who we also extend recognition
to
who we value and this is why the
position of the master
ironically is not a good position
they recognize other masters they don't
recognize those who are giving them
the recognition that they're demanding
that is the slaves
right or anytime that we have a a status
and privilege differential like that
there's a problem
with with that sort of thing which isn't
to say that we have to undermine all
hierarchies we could have hierarchies of
actual merit rather than just assumed
merit that goes a little bit
beyond this so recognition and
reciprocity with the other he says at
the foundation of hegelian dialectic
there's an
absolute reciprocity which must be
emphasized
it is in the degree to which i go beyond
my own immediate being that i apprehend
the existence of the other
now notice what he says here as a
natural and
more than natural reality we recognize
other people not just as these sort of
spiritual
airy you know beings beyond the body no
we recognize each other through our
bodies
which means if we're thinking in terms
of race through
our skin through all the cultural
assumptions that go into that
we that is a possibility for us though
so this recognition has to be made
reciprocal and often it isn't
and there's a third component to this
that he's getting from hegel
that is uh you know in some respects
really problematic
hegel himself is trying to figure out
how we go beyond this
after the master slave dialectic this
need for conflict
and risk how do you know that somebody
values something they're willing to
sacrifice and risk for it
so he says that here we go
self-consciousness accepts the risk of
its life
consequently it threatens the other in
its physical being he goes on and says
human reality in itself for itself can
be achieved only through
conflict and through the risk that
conflict implies
what does this risk mean i go beyond
life
toward a supreme good something else
that that is the transformation of
subjective certainty of my own worth
into a universally valid
objective truth i'm looking for
something that is not merely subjective
something that is
now objective something that is in the
society
as an assumption as something that is
enacted
that's a lot to ask and
here's where the analysis gets really
interesting
fanon says well you know hegel
he he had the master slave dialectic and
then what comes
after it we're going to take a different
turn
so he thinks that the case of people
in the united states and i think you can
also make a case given what he said
about
south africa earlier um
that the there is this master slave
dialectic
going on writ large within the society
he says that um
i i he says i'm going to analyze the
french negro for the american negroes
cast in a different play
in the united states the negro battles
and is battled there are laws that
little by little are invalidated under
the constitution
there are other laws that forbid certain
forms of discrimination
and we can be sure that nothing is going
to be given free there is war there are
defeats cruces
victories right so there is this
struggle of the you know
in law not slave but actually being
treated
as slave particularly in political
economic
social conditions legal conditions as
well think about segregation in the
american south
and the illegality of lynchings that he
mentions going on in here
there is a struggle that's going on and
it's possible to attain
something through that struggle that is
outside
of the master slave dialectic as hegel
sketches
it out um we might also think about
other parts of africa
um you know the belgian congo in
particular
right at the time that that he's he's
writing
um other colonies
of other countries but then he talks
about the french
and the french situation being a bit
different
why well in in the french colonies
slavery gets
ended in a way that doesn't allow for
the hegelian dialectic to actually
take shape so he says
he is reluct he who is reluctant to
recognize me oppresses
opposes me in a savage struggle i'm
willing to accept convulsions of death
invincible dissolution but also the
possibility of the impossible
but the other can recognize me without
struggle
and here he brings up hegel again in the
master slave dialectic
he says that the individual who's not
staked his life may no doubt be
recognized as a person
but he's not attained the truth of this
recognition as an independent
self-consciousness
so now he's talking not about about
everybody he says this has to do with
the the french
uh uh colonized blacks
historically the negro steeped in the
inessentiality of servitude was set free
by his master he did not fight for his
freedom
out of slavery the negro burst into the
list where his masters stood
like those servants who are allowed once
every year to dance in the drawing room
he's looking for a prop he's not become
a master
when there are no longer slaves there's
no longer masters and he said the negro
is a slave
who's been allowed to assume the
attitude of a master the white man is a
master who allowed his slaves to eat at
his
table and and he says that this upheaval
reached the negroes from without the
black man was
acted upon values that had not been
created by his actions
danced in a huge world around him and
a little bit later he says they haven't
fought for their freedom
now here's where it gets really uh
interesting he says
from time to time he's fought for
liberty and justice but these are always
white liberty and white justice that his
values secreted by his
master and so he winds up in a situation
where he's been given
what he says he wants but he's not given
it in the way that he
needs demands desires it
and the same white world that values
people differently
where it's connected not just with skin
color but economics with
culture is still in place
and he has to sort of push against it
but he doesn't have
the you might say justification for for
pushing against it and then he says that
well another possibility is
seeking out conflict you find the
conflict
where it is he says the former slave
needs a challenge to his humanity
he wants a conflict a riot but it's too
late the french negro is doomed to bite
himself and just to bite
a little bit later he says this
situation becomes unbearable
unable to ever be sure whether the white
man considers him consciousness in
itself for itself in this hegelian way
granting recognition he must forever
obser absorb himself in uncovering
resistance
opposition challenge and he talks about
young negroes sought to maintain their
alterity alternative rupture conflict
battle and fanon says well that doesn't
actually
overcome this so what we have here
are different ways in which the hegelian
dynamic or dialectic can go that aren't
really described in
hegel's own thought but have to be
diagnosed by somebody like fanon
in in this work this isn't the final
point in what fondon has to say but this
is
where his consideration of hegel
recognition and black white relations
effectively ends
you